uh what what made you decide to speak
out publicly so the biggest thing for me
has just been I thought maybe if I
waited a year or however much time that
I've been these feelings I felt
unfairness the this is not the truth
this is not just would go away and they
never really did and I just spent this
last year just kind of living
vicariously through oh Riley's going and
doing these great things she's going to
accomplish all these things we need to
have done and she's made great strides
but I am still feeling so passionately
about this that I want to join her and I
know that the more voices we have and
I'm hoping even more people will speak
out the more voices we have the more
powerful this will be